In this lesson, we'll talk most specifically about what you should expect from
CS7637. We'll start by talking about the learning goals, the learning outcomes,
and the learning strategies that we'll use for this class.
Then we'll discuss the class projects and assessments. That will lead us
to talking about something called Computational Psychometrics, which is one of
the multi-weighting principles behind the projects in this class.
Next we'll talk about the Raven's Progressive Matrices test of intelligence.
I think you're going to find it fascinating. The Raven's Progressive Matrices
test of intelligence are the most commonly used tests of human intelligence. And
that test was the target of the projects in this class. Very ambitious,
you're going to enjoy it. FInally we'll discuss something commonly
reoccuring principle in this class and you should be on the lookout for them.